Oh
hello and we're glad you've joined us
for this live webinar prepare for
success
GMP cell banks as part of a staged
standardized platform-style cell
production process I'm Suzy Valdez of
lab routes and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher manufacturer of GMP
give Co cell therapy systems reagents
for pluripotent derived cell therapy
development for more information on our
sponsor please visit them at thermo
Fisher comm now let's get started you
can submit questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh on your mind
to do so simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
the send button will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have
experienced technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation simply click on
the support tab found at the top right
of your presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and those offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process for
obtaining your credits I now present
today's speaker Benjamin fryer Ben is
the CEO and co-founder of plura stiix
incorporated providing GMP pre expanded
pluripotent stem cells contract
development services and consultancy for
groups and company developing cell and
tissue therapies Ben has almost 25 years
of experience as a leader and scientist
in large pharma academia and startup
companies developing combination
products and cell therapies for complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen without further ado let me
introduce you to our presenter Ben you
may now begin your presentation
you
thank you Miss felt as I'd like to thank
miss Valdes from lab roots and also Kyle
berry and Amanda summers from thermo
Fisher Scientific for the opportunity to
present here today to to all of you so
today as was mentioned I'll be talking
about manufacturing GMP cell banks as
part of a staged process and why it is
so important and how that's incorporated
into cell therapy manufacturing and
we'll also talk really about the
critical reagents maybe most importantly
the quality of the reagents and raw
materials also known as ancillary
materials that have to go in early in
the development process and why it is so
important to incorporate quality
materials early on
so as an overview I think most people
that are listening to this webinar know
that pluripotent stem cells either from
human embryonic stem cells or induced
pluripotent stem cells have been
described in literature for at least the
last 12 years for induced pluripotent
stem cells and over 20 years ago from
the groundbreaking work from Jamie
Thompson in late 90s showing that human
embryonic stem cells can be derived and
expanded based on that work there's been
a lot of proof of concept studies that
have been done either with human
embryonic stem cells or with induced
pluripotent stem cells also just called
pscs here pluripotent stem cells make
cells or tissues that can be
transplanted into animal models of
disease and can essentially cure those
diseases that includes things like
blindness diabetes heart disease spinal
cord injuries potentially things like
Parkinson's so of course these these
cures or treatments are very exciting
but translating the promise of those PSC
derived therapies to reality or patients
requires really a rigorous an often
expensive and definitely highly
regulated manufacturing that is broken
up into unit operations so you don't
just start start growing cells make your
product and ship it out you have unit
operations that define how that process
is manufactured and it all starts with
making the starting material that is to
say the master cell bank and then from
that you would make working cell banks
and as part of that you need to make
sure that those are high quality cell
banks that start with high quality
starting material that will meet today's
regulatory requirements but because the
process for development so long you need
to consider that they might need to
exceed the current regulatory
requirements to meet tomorrow's
regulatory requirements and as part of
that integrating high quality raw
materials ancillary materials and in
this case we'll call them ancillary raw
materials into the product development
and manufacturing starting at the very
beginning with the cell source and
manufacturing of the master cell bank in
doing this it reduces process risk
regulatory risk and long-term it reduces
the economic risk of potentially delayed
product release or potentially the
company or the sponsors not having
enough money to continue so where are we
right now in terms of pluripotent stem
cell Drive there appease when we look at
the the state of the art for other
biological manufacturing that is to say
antibodies proteins for say enzyme
replacement or vaccines or even virus
made for other cell therapy
manufacturing for things like Kartik
there's a host of cell lines that are
available and they're already GMP and
are ready to go so that would be things
like gel where a GK for for protein
production Cho for antibodies HEK and
vero cells for virus manufacturing and
they are essentially plug-and-play
meaning you can go to a contract
manufacturer and there's a host of them
in the United States and in Europe and
Asia and they will help you to develop a
process that is defined relatively
affordable they'll start with mostly if
not all animal origin free raw materials
ALS and they will make you starting from
one of those lines tube is already GMP
they will make you a seed bank and you
can pick a clone make a master cell bank
and then proceed from there and all of
this can be routinely done from
derivation as a fee-for-service so you
could have a virtual company and do it
all yourself from basically an office
and have a contract manufacturer do it
all that is really not the case right
now with pluripotent stem cell derived
era piece it were much earlier in the
development phase for that as an
industry right now every trial sponsor
whether it's a university and non-profit
or for-profit company currently has to
develop and use their own process and
this can be inconsistent so even if you
have the same starting material the same
genetic material whether it's for
example let's say you have an h1 line
that you could get as a starting
material from from Y sell different
expansion processes by different
companies or different labs will give
different downstream
processing and differentiation to a
product cell and another thing to keep
in mind that's a problem within the
field right now is a high cost of raw
materials and the raw materials
themselves are often research use only
there are a couple companies for example
thermo Fisher stem cell technologies
they have some GMP or clinical grade
material that is available for use early
on but many other manufacturers don't
have that that's something to keep in
mind and when you're making these
starting material you need to make sure
that you're considering the life cycle
so for example if you're developing the
products can take five to ten years from
the time you start the development
process the early preclinical studies
until the time you get FDA approval from
marketing then from there you're looking
at tend of potentially up to thirty plus
years for your product lifecycle so at
the minimum you're looking at 15 years
of supporting manufacturing from ups
from a single bank and ideally up to if
you're lucky 35 40 years or supporting
the product life cycle so the underlying
master cell bank has to be designed to
keep that in mind can you can you make
enough without changing the bank and the
reason why changing the bank is so
problematic is for given the
inconsistencies within pluripotent stem
cells the early Bank is is the the
foundation it's what you build on and
you don't want to change it the FDA
requires essentially biological
manufacturing to be a defined process
because the end products are often hard
to fully characterize so changing they
say the process is the product which
means if you change the process you're
essentially changing the product and if
you do that you need to demonstrate
comparability there's three levels of
doing that one would be just in vitro
assays another could be in vivo assays
in an animal model but if the FDA
determines that the process has changed
sufficiently and they want full proof of
comparability you could end up having to
do an additional clinical trial to show
a comparability so changing a process as
its own internal risks and the most
expensive outcome could be redoing a
clinical trial so starting with a good
master cell bank is really important so
when we look at the the current state of
clinical trials and regenerative
medicine right now there are 875
companies most don't just over half of
those are located in North America and
those companies and other universities
nonprofits are running about a total of
977 clinical trials in the regenerative
medicine space of those about 60 of them
are with clear potent stem cell derived
cells or tissues and this is from
clinical trials.gov
so there's a lot of people that are in
the space but it's I'd say still early
and most of those trials are in phase
one or phase early phase two and they
start for the pluripotent stem cell
derived therapies they start with either
one of two sources on the left you can
see embryonic stem cells on the right
would be induced pluripotent stem cells
embryonic stem cells are come from
donated in vitro fertilization material
that would be otherwise discarded
usually the the donors have elected to
to either dispose of the material or
donate it and so it's plated out the
inner cell mass grows out you get a cell
line and that cell line can be expanded
and banked all in a laboratory under
controlled conditions
that's where human embryonic stem cells
come from one line comes from one embryo
when you're working with induced
pluripotent stem cells those can come
from any nucleated cell any somatic cell
with a nucleus and there are multiple
methods to to manufacture them there's
you can use virus multiple viral sources
Lenti add no retrovirus those are a
little bit less likely to be used for or
clinical grade product but right now
using plasmid or episomes
is an alternative and of course direct
nodulation with protein or mrna or a mix
to induce lower potency in an adult cell
back to a higher potent state in the end
embryonic stem cells and induced
pluripotent stem cells if they are of
good quality they should be basically
indistinguishable it shouldn't be easy
to tell where they came from they should
have the same expansion properties the
banking processes between them should be
the same so therefore the reagents and
the raw materials that are used for that
process should
be applicable to both types of cells the
phenotype what you would consider player
potency should be the same and they
should differentiate relatively
similarly knowing that there is
differences from line to line but they
should be able to form all three
lineages of ectoderm endoderm and
mesoderm in the end those those
pluripotent stem cells are what are used
in the potent stem cell field so as
you're taking this and you're developing
your product starting with these
pluripotent stem cells you're going to
have to follow if you're working with
the FDA they're phased development
scheme starts first with proof of
concept and this would be the same
whether you're working with a drug or a
small molecule or a biological or a cell
therapy you'd have to show that you've
got some proof of concept that they
should have some efficacious benefit
that you could extrapolate for for a
human being then you would move into
your preclinical studies which most
critically involves pharmacology and
toxicology and for cell therapies those
are often mixed or biologicals and small
molecules they can often be done
separately but for preclinical studies
in cell therapy they're often combined
into the same animal model or multiple
animal models that package is then put
together along with other work including
CMC and your clinical trial plan
planning and you file an IND indication
for a new drug and if you get the green
light and approval from the FDA you can
begin a series of escalating clinical
trial phases starting with phase one
phase two and phase three and at the end
of all that you'll have enough data to
show that it's most importantly safe but
also importantly efficacious and then
you can file for a biological licensing
approval which gives you a PLA and
approval to sell your product which
point you'd have to put phase four
post-marketing surveillance further for
the topic of a master cell bank where
it's probably most important to think
about this is the first four bullets you
have the opportunity to have what used
to be called a pre pre-ind meeting I'm
now called an interact meeting with the
the FDA where you can get some of their
early advice on how to develop your
product and a few key questions that you
should probably answer in
in advance of your pre-ind meeting at
the point when you're prepared to do
your pre-ind meeting you want to make
sure that you've got an idea of what
your product is going to look like and
you don't necessarily have to have a
master cell bank a GMP master cell bank
at this point but you need to have a
good idea of how you're going to make it
because at this point you're going to
get approval from the FDA for what you
believe you're acceptable toxicology and
pharmacology animal models are and this
is critical because this is an expensive
process it could cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars to run these
studies and they have something that
money can't buy which is time embedded
in them so if you're going to use a
pluripotent stem cell derived therapy
you're going to have to do some sort of
a tumor study or Terra teratoma
formation study and this is often to the
life of the animal so that can be
anywhere between six to twelve months of
waiting to see if animals develop tumors
and that is required to start with
you're your master cell bank the FDA as
you can see the link below they require
the manufacturing process of the
cellular product used in the preclinical
study should be as similar to the
intended clinical product as possible
meaning you should start with your
master cell bank that you're going to
use for your clinical grave
manufacturing so you don't want it you
can't do those studies until you have
that master cell bank and so you can see
how early on you're locked in you
haven't even filed your int and you need
to have locked in one of your
manufacturing processes once you've got
all those pharmacology and toxicology
studies you'll file your IND and you'll
be able to move into manufacturing for
your Phase one clinical trial
the FDA has an explicit and implicit
expectation that you will improve your
manufacturing process from your Phase
one clinical trials through to the end
of your phase 2b clinical trials at the
beginning before you begin phase three
you have to have locked your
manufacturing process but that allows
you some downstream improvements but the
one thing that it's very difficult to
improve is the master cell bank although
you can improve lots of other things by
the end of phase 2 it's really hard to
to make any changes to the master cell
bank because that essentially introduces
comparability risk
so when you think about this if you kind
of like break it up into what I've
called process units or unit operations
when you're doing the research work it
really is almost seamless you have your
starting material might be a cell bank
or cell line that's floating around the
lab maybe researchers grad students
postdocs have traded the line around
everybody's got their own so-called bank
or master cell bank that they use
passage number may not be well tracked
the processing is not necessarily
consistent but everybody seems to get a
pretty good result which is why you're
you're moving forward and trying to
raise money to to make this into a
clinical rate process you expand the
cells most you know you might see them a
little lighter one day or a little
heavier another day to make sure that
you don't have to come in and pass cells
on a Saturday or a Sunday and at the end
you have a differentiation process which
works pretty well in a small scale and
then those are put into either distant
vitro studies or they're put into in
vivo studies in your animal model and
it's relatively seamless it's often done
by one maybe two or three people but
it's a small team at a minimum or a
maximum I should say when you move into
clinical grade manufacturing that's that
early part that starting material is
broken up really into three unit
operations and it's very tightly
regulated and ideally it should be
locked early in development that's
derivation so if it's an embryonic stem
cell if that would be anywhere from
getting the donation of the blastocyst
or the embryo in the case of an induced
pluripotent stem cell it would be how
you're manufacturing the the IPS lines
in the very beginning what are the
materials you use to derive that that
induced pluripotent stem cell expansion
process then can be broke up into a seed
material and frozen and you can
characterize and pick your your starting
material once you've picked it then you
make your master cell Bank and all of
this is relatively tightly locked and
this should all be done with with high
quality ancillary materials high quality
raw materials so that you don't have to
go back and repeat this later on there's
any questions about the quality of those
materials once you move into the later
stages shown in pink on the right which
would be making the working cell Bank
then thawing a working cell bank which
could contain anywhere between one and
five million cells in the vial you'll
expand that up and the seed train really
just means you're growing up lots of
pluripotent stem cells for your eventual
differentiation process so you might
need to make hundreds of millions of
cells or even potentially billions of
pluripotent stem cells at that point
you're ready to differentiate those
cells into your product and then you
have finish and fill whether it's cold
stored and delivered directly to the
clinic or you have cryopreservation
somewhere in that process and then
that's delivered to the to the to the
patient or to the point of care all that
in pink you could potentially make
process changes in optimization prior to
process lock in advance of your
registration trial which is usually
Phase three but if you have to say an
orphan designation or an advanced
regenerative medicine application that's
approved that could potentially be phase
2b or something like that but you need
to potentially optimize the process from
the point of the master cell bank
derivation and you have room in time for
that you don't necessarily have it for
the the banking process of the master
cell bank and so if we look at like
really what goes into the workflow
that's that's used for making a master
cell bank for an intended clinical
product it has to be made under GMP good
manufacturing process practice and this
starts first and foremost by where
you're going to do it it has to be done
in a clean environment and that's
because most of the operations for
making a master cell bank are open open
would be just kind of your standard
6-well plate or a tea flask you know
you've got pipetting that are done open
in in more advanced biological
processing often things are closed and
considered to be sterile that can be
done in a room environment but for any
sort of a septic processing it has to be
done in a biosafety cabinet which would
be an ISO five environment inside of an
cleanroom which would be an ISO seven
environment that
room and that that biosafety cabinet
have to have HEPA filtered air and the
the environment is monitored by things
like settling plates active particle
monitors and culture culture plates for
monitoring for both just total particle
burden and colony forming units any sort
of instruments that are used in that
environment have to be qualified for use
and for work by installation operational
performance qualification any of the
operators and verifiers who work in that
environment have to be gowning qualified
qualified to be in the room and also
qualified to perform the the unit
operations that are going to be done and
all of that has to be captured within a
batch record that is a their paper and
electronic document that verifies and
tracks all the work that was done and
was so that there's a record of what was
done and there also has to be a system
to track if any sort of deviations occur
if anything that was unplanned or not
captured within the batch record to
determine on a risk analysis of it if it
impacted the quality of the product
anything that comes in and is used in
that environment has to have
traceability so that would be any sort
of raw materials or excipient that are
going to come in and that means that the
product has to come in with a
certificate of analysis a CFA and
they're held in the warehouse in a
quarantine area until they're approved
for use and that provides incoming goods
control for anything that's coming in
and one thing that's not on the slide
but it keep in mind is that any sort of
supplier is often audited or usually
should be audited either with a paper
audit indicating that there's some
quality supply chain system used by the
manufacturing system used by the
supplier or potentially depending on on
the risk of the incoming product or the
phase of the manufacturing an on-site
audit by quality assurance from the
sponsor
nothing that keep in mind is that the
donor tissue the cell itself whether
it's a human embryonic stem cell or an
induced pluripotent stem cell you need
to make sure that you have fully
consented donor release of that material
and this is critical because in today's
day and age where genome gene sequencing
and identity is so easily performed you
could quite easily
assuming that everything's been
anonymized and randomized and you have
fully donor consent that donor could be
traced and very easily and so you can
imagine how family might want to make
sure that that they were compensated if
that the donor consent wasn't fully in
place and then finally so assuming you
have all those things you've got a fully
consented donor including commercial
rights to use those cells and all Rob
material traceability cleanroom etc
you've made your bank now the bank has
to be released based on assays four four
four four or more things these are the
key for safety identity purity and
viability and so when you're making a
master cell bank and also working cell
bank these these these criteria bold for
both both form you'll have to test for
phenotype and identity a purity of the
of the bank the karyotype meaning that
has to be genetically stable it has to
have only one donor and that donor has
to be human but there's multiple ways to
do that but right now for human type
'button stem cells probably the best way
to do that would be to use short tendon
repeat we test for sterility and that
would include mycoplasma fungus and
bacterial growth and then also endotoxin
which can be either a result of any sort
of risk from your your raw materials or
bacterial growth within the product then
the product before it's frozen and after
it's frozen you would check for
viability usually by a qualified method
which could include things like dye
exclusion and some of those are old
tested methods like tripe and blue if
they didn't bromide are pretty and
iodide there are a lot of other methods
but in the FDA requirement is that the
bank after thaw is greater than 70
percent viable and then finally and
maybe most important you need to make
sure that the the bank functions as you
would want it to in your process and
that would be sponsor specific
differentiation to whatever it is your
fate of interest and so that's for
releasing a master a working cell bank
the master bank has a deeper dive so
when you're releasing it you'll also
have to look for any sort of viral
potential contaminant or infection in
that line there's qpcr assays for the
top ones including things like HIV as
rt-pcr for RNA viruses cv you have then
for and of course because they're PCR
they are primer based so you know the
sequence but then there's also the risk
that there could be viruses that you
don't even know about though that
includes adventitious viral contaminants
for nonspecific reverse transcriptase
and then there's in vitro and in vivo
assays that are that are intended to
determine if there's any virus in the
the bank so you would kill culture with
MRC 5 euro or a 5 for 9 cells and do it
in vitro assay you'd also do an in vivo
assay there's direct inoculation of eggs
or rodents to look for for viral
contaminants also if your product has
ever come in contact with any sort of
bovine material you'd also have to
potentially do bovine virus detection
and and if you have used anything that
was porcine like trip trypsin drive from
from pig gut or you've told cultured
them with Mouse feeders you'd have to do
porcine or murine virus panels so it's
really important that you have if you
can get animal origin free recombinant
and human materials only then you will
reduce the risk of having to do any
additional viral testing it's also
really important that you understand the
material supply chain of your suppliers
how did they make those materials
because that's where additional risk
comes in any of that raw material
contact puts that that master cell Bank
and therefore your entire process and
potentially company at risk if you don't
have high quality materials coming in so
I've given you a lot of tables give you
a picture just to kind of describe this
so like I said we're looking at unit
operations cell banking process you
start at unit one and that
really making your your seed materially
seed bank and with the with the
embryonic stem cell it starts with a
with an embryo or a blastocyst it's
cultured out and in the case of induced
pluripotent stem cells would be your
donors somatic cells that are induced
back to player potency you might either
bulk passage or single cell clone and
then you would have potentially one or
more seed banks if you could take those
banks and before you move on to unit
operation to which is the actual master
cell bank would take that material and
you would test it you'd want to make
sure that it was genetically stable if
it's an IPS cell you didn't have any say
Sima core for incorporation into the
wrong places you'd want to make sure
that it was had a nice population
doubling time it didn't grow too fast it
didn't grow too slow it was a nice
stable line and probably most
importantly if you're making a product
that it differentiates to the fate that
you want so now you've got a seed bank
and let's say that's somewhere between
five and 20 vials you're going to take
one of those vials and you're going to
return to the GMB facility and you're
going to make your master cell bank and
that's going to take somewhere between
say two to five passages you start in a
small either a 6-well plate or a small
tea flask you can grow that out into
cell factory or a cell stack and or
multiple tea flasks and you'll have
enough cells to make 100 or more files
of the master cell bank that can then be
used thought and used to make a working
cell bank and nearly the same process as
the master cell bank and in this case
when we talk about the life line at a
lifetime life cycle of the product i'm a
hundred vials of a master cell bank can
make about 100,000 total product Lots
because each vial of master cell bank
can make about a hundred miles or more
of working cell bank so you just
multiply that out assuming that each
each working cell bank vial can make a
product lot that's ten thousand possible
product Lots from relatively small banks
and assuming you do two production runs
a month or just a little bit more and
it's about twenty-five production runs a
year which would be a really high number
normally you'd want to do a lot less
than that but let's say you're you're
really running full gun
and full bore and you've got that 25
product runs product Lots being
manufactured you're off of this simple
scheme that would be enough for 40 years
of your product lifecycle so it's enough
to support a long long term
manufacturing process so just in summary
you've got your see material process
starting either with an embryo or a
small amount of donor cells you're going
to make somewhere less than say 20 vials
you're going to check those those vials
in that Bank for do they work in your
process are they either the right
material then you're going to have to
release them you're going to want to
know in the case of an IPS cell if you
have any sort of residual virus or
plasma and corporation or episomes left
in the cytoplasm you're going to check
to make sure are they still are they
Player potent are the genetically stable
and of course are they clean
are they sterile and do they function in
your process then you pick one you move
into your master cell Bank and now
you're doing this much larger release
specification Compendium release for
sterility and the toxin mycoplasma
checking for their pluripotency are they
are they the right identity are they
genetically stable do they function and
in the case of IPS cells do they have
any sort of insertions that you don't
want and then a working cell Bank is a
sub subset of those relief
specifications and in each case you
don't have to make a lot of vials I mean
this isn't a large production process
the thing about it is it takes a lot of
time and issue you can see here on the
third or fourth line time to completion
you know it could take 14 to 21 days or
more for the seed material you know 20
20 plus days potentially you're around
20 days for a master cell bank and
another say 15 to 20 days for your
working cell bank if you add that all up
you're looking at just in time alone
spent in a GMP facility of about 7 to 8
weeks and so this is expensive GMP
facilities are not cheap operations are
not cheap and so you need to click plan
these out very carefully in advance
because you don't want to change the
master cell bank the cost even if you do
it early on is quite expensive
GMP suite with reagents and labor and I
think these are on low-end numbers there
are tens of thousands of dollars the
actual bank release testing for the the
tables I showed
obviously those are hundreds of
thousands of dollars so they're quite
expensive and the time is something that
money just can't buy time just to
generate in test those cell banks can
take nine months or longer including the
the tumor studies they're required for
your toxicology studies to to sponsor an
hour support an IND filing and so the
risk to the sponsor at the cell bank
isn't done properly are if you change it
cell banks by the nature are inherently
variable in performance you can end up
having to go back and reoptimize your
manufacturing for your differentiation
and that cost could be millions of
dollars the additional cost could be
incomparability requirements that that
any regulatory agency might require and
so if you imagine that you've got a
product that could be a blockbuster drug
meaning makes a billion dollars a year
or more and you end up taking a nine or
twelve month delay because you had to
remake a master cell bank that's a
billion dollars in cost it's money that
actually has been actually realized but
it could be the difference between
success and failure of a company
especially if you have a competitor that
your neck and neck with and they get
there first
your your you could end up losing
completely
so just to review the risks to the
master cell bank and I'm the slide after
this is really how to mitigate these
risks you want to make sure you have
proper donor consent for the incoming
raw material but that is the cell itself
you want to make sure that any sort of
raw materials or ancillary materials
they're used in you're making your bank
are of high quality so if you're going
to use feeder cells
I'd recommend GMP human feeder cells if
you're going to use well I would
recommend against Mouse feeder cells you
can use them for example H 1 and H 9
have been used for human clinical trials
but they are not there they're
considered xeno genic lines meaning
they've been in contact with another
species cells and so it's not something
that you'd want to do if you can avoid
it but it's not it's not a game stopper
if you're using any sort of bovine
component in your process FBS or bovine
albumin want to make sure it comes from
a qualified herd meaning a usda-approved
heard that has a certificate of origin
and this is because of prion disease
there is no assay for it the only way to
prevent it in your manufacturing is to
is to start with high quality material
and if you can't prove that later on
that could be a game stopper so TSE has
a real risks here you're processing your
product the media I'm depending on how
it's made there's warehoused actual mice
in the warehouse can can transmit virus
to the components and so you want to use
media from a reputable vendor who
actually tests for that your growth
factor should be all Deeley human
recombinant and if possible animal
origin free and that includes for
pluripotent media things like insulin
bf/gf and tgf-beta and other growth
factors that can be in the media your
small molecules if possible should be
filtered and your DMSO should be a
pharma grade cell culture plastic
usually if you're working from something
like Nalgene dunk or Corning you're
going to get a very high quality product
but some people use cheaper sources I'd
recommend against it go with a with a
with a reputable old and trusted vendor
if you're using a coating which most
clear potent stem cells require a
coating avoid Maitre gel if you can
that's that's a really are you--oh
product you want to go with
thing that is manufactured fit for
purpose and that would be a recombinant
product or a synthetic product like RG d
or recombinant laminin and for any sort
of human donor materials you want to
make sure that you have a certificate of
analysis that they are clean for any
sort of viruses and just keep in mind
that the real risk here is is two things
transmissible spongiform encephalopathy
the prion disease and viral
contamination and you can test for viral
contamination later on but you can't
test for TSE so you need to make sure
that anything that's made on any product
that's made with bovine source in your
supply chain or that is a bovine source
material that you're using directly has
come from a USDA certified herd or New
Zealand Australia herd so in terms of
how do you mitigate this the USP has a
very clear guidance on this that 10:43
was recently issued a couple years back
and it talks about how to incorporate
ancillary materials or Celgene and
tissue engineered products into your
manufacturing and they do this by
providing a four tier table system so
Tier one is the lowest risk tier 4 is
the highest risk and tier 4 really
includes a lot of the things I'm talking
about previously like bovine derived
materials any sort of xeno product
anything that's not intended for
potentially incorporation into an
infusible or directly treatable product
things that are for Diagnostics a or for
research would be in Tier three or Tier
four and they provide guidance for
qualifying the use of materials so if a
material is say research use only but
you have to use it because there is no
GMP or self-therapy grade product they
provide guidance for qualifying that
material to use in manufacturing your
cell gene or tissue engineered product
and that is key because you know early
on the FDA and other regulatory agencies
wreckin recognize there is a risk you
can't always get a GMP reagent if you're
if you're pushing the envelope and
trying to make a new therapy they do
expect that you work with a supplier
that is committed to improving their
quality systems and parallel as you
advance
through your phased development to to
commercial manufacturing for for human
use products and that means you really
want to make sure from the very
beginning you work to integrate high
quality raw materials and ancillary
materials into your manufacturing
process from the very first seed bank
onward and that means if you can use GMP
or an animal origin free products as
soon as possible especially for your
cell banking and source all your raw
materials if possible from suppliers
experienced in supporting cell therapy
development ideally they should be
stable long-term partners because
they're going to have to commit to to
supplying that product to you as long as
you're making your product and if they
do so that will reduce your risk of
potential disruptions things like back
orders I know if you're in a lab and
something's backwards six weeks it's you
know it's a hassle if you've got a GMP
suite set up and you've got operators
and you've paid for that time and you're
back ordered on a critical reagent you
have to pay for that time that can cost
a lot of money product changes should be
clearly communicated to you if you're
using them and you don't want to have to
worry about any sort of discontinued
products because that can of course
create great risk in your in your
manufacturing system and you want to
identify if possible more than one
source for your raw materials ideally at
least two suppliers avoid sole supplier
products if possible I know that's not
always possible but but that's something
to keep in mind it just reduces your
risk as a manufacturer or as a sponsor
so in summary I think I've hopefully
communicated how important it is from
seed material on through your master
cell bank all the way through to end
product manufacturing how important it
is especially is beginning to use high
quality raw materials from an
established reputable vendor as early as
possible because those raw material
risks extend throughout the supply chain
and they put the entire project and
product at risk if they're not dealt
with you want to book and future forward
planning you want to know where you're
going to be where you want to be knowing
that's going to take many years and you
want to anticipate increased regulatory
stringency over time or your product and
so you don't just want to meet today's
two
you want to know that tomorrow standards
are going to be a little higher and you
want to try and meet those in advance so
that you can at least pass the bar for
tomorrow even though you greatly exceed
it today and all of this if you do this
and put this in place now you can avoid
the loss of time money and potentially
catastrophic risk to your product or
your company by generating a high
quality seed and master cell banks in
the beginning that can sustain the
product throughout its lifecycle so my
last slide just a little bit about plura
sticks I won't talk too much about it
but I'd like to thank everybody who has
come today and watched and listen to
this talk and if if you have any
questions I'm happy to take any
questions you have at this time thank
you
and Thank You Ben for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for before I
ask the final first question we have a
question for you have you worked in a
GMP environment before this question
will now pop up on your screen and
thanks for your participation
look at our first questions coming in
from our audience then can you make a
cell line GMP if it wasn't originally
generated in a GMP environment
excellent question so this is a common
question that's asked and I think the
answer right now I think is yes so for
example the 89 line that is available
from YSL was made under under research
conditions so that would have been
considered a research master cell bank
that that question that that bank has
been used essentially as the seed bank
so as a unit operation and that that
research master cell bank becomes the
so-called seed material a vial of that
is then transferred into a GMP
environment and entire batch record and
process is developed around that and
then it's manufactured and released and
there's a essentially a risk assessment
that has to be done on all the materials
that were used to make that line in the
beginning so it's kind of a way of kind
of figuring out what other additional
viral panels you should you should look
for I guess the biggest risk with any
sort of with doing something in that
manner is that you need to make sure you
have early passage cells and it's
actually not given that the FDA or other
regulatory agencies will will accept it
by the time you get to filing your PLA
so you might be able to make your
product early on but you might be
essentially pigeon-holed into a very
small indication so for example if you
wanted to go for show that you were
making with a neurons and you wanted to
treat a specific type of blindness
you might only be able to use that
product for that specific type of
blindness to be able to add on
indications or other therapeutic areas
you may not be able to do it because
they would consider that product to be
too high of risk and so you end up
basically having to restart the process
so I guess the question the simple
answer is yes it's possible to take a
research bank and make it into a GMP
master cell bank right now but I think
if if you can afford it if it's possible
it's better to make the master cell bank
from
a GMP source in the very very beginning
Thank You Ben and is there a difference
between a research master cell bank and
a GMP master cell bank and can our
research bank be converted to GMP bank
during development I would say probably
you can I like I said it's possible to
convert from one bank to another I just
I think that it the cost is really the
issue in terms of risk down down down
down the line and so I would recommend
if possible especially if you're working
with an IPS cell start with a GMP seed
material and a GMP master cell bank
embryonic stem cells a little bit harder
but it is possible to take a research
master cell bank make that your seed
material and make a GMP master cell bank
later on
Thank You ban and one audience member
would like to know to your slide 18
point how important is it to you
quality by design so quality by design
is essentially used asking the question
beforehand how you know testing the
parameters of your of your process so
it's a little bit easier to do with a
master cell bank really what you're
looking for is you're looking for
population doublings and essentially
quality you're controlling for four
risks and stresses in the process early
on I think it's it's important to use
but I don't know exactly how how much
work is required to do quality by design
early on I think having the good master
cell bank probably feeds more directly
into quality by design later on in the
process so that you have a starting
consistent process and product that you
can a bank that you can use for
manufacturing later on
Thank You Ben and why do you need a GMP
cell trying to make study material for
pre ind-enabling studies so the risk
well so the request in a pre-ind well in
an IND submission is that you have to
have shown that your material is number
one and most importantly it's safe and
so the safety question for stem cell any
sort of cell which has the ability to
grow and form all the other tissues is
that it could form a tumor and so the
question is that you know you have a
master cell bank that master cell bank
is where it's essentially the starting
point for all things so if you generate
different master cell banks the
potential is that one of them could have
a different risk for sorts or tumors or
for ectopic tissue formations so if you
do your combination pharmacology
toxicology studies with your master cell
banks and they're not there they're not
the one that you're going to use in
patients the FDA or some other
regulatory is going to wonder why or
what the other risk is and so this is
probably the biggest problem with with
trying to change master cell banks
you'll end up having to redo that study
so you could potentially use one master
cell Bank of this GMP for your pre
ind-enabling studies but if you want to
switch to another bank you'll probably
end up having to do those those teratoma
toxicology studies again and that's just
cuts down it's just it's a time cost so
we could end up having to repeat human
clinical trial studies so it's I think
it's really critical to get that that
done first
thank you and thank you to our audience
members for their questions that are
coming in then our next question is is
it important to have a MCB if the cells
being used are from the source they are
going back into from for example from
patient a back to patient a and no one
else yeah so this would be essentially
almost like the autologous model of of
cells so if there's this question of
minimal manipulation so for example if
you're pulling cells out and you're
going to put them right back in so for
example if your banking blood from
somebody for a surgery and you won't if
you want to make sure that they have a
blood supply that you could infuse back
into them that's considered minimal
manipulation and you won't have to to
make a master cell bank of that but if
you're going to expand those cells and
you're going to change them you're going
to end up having to do a proper release
on those on that product and that
release panel is is expensive I guess it
really depends on the product so for
example if you're making a pluripotent
stem cell derived product you're going
to have to make a master cell bank and
you're going to have to release the
master cell bank and the real question
there is the risk to the patient and the
risk comes from the raw material so
virus and sterility can be a problem
based on whatever you're doing to expand
those cells and to change them so you'll
need a master cell bank the the full
release panel may not be it may not be
to be so extensive but you will need it
a master cell bank thank you and then
does the master cell bank strategy
change if the pluripotent stem cell is
genetically modified example expresses a
transgene or how the gene edit this is a
is that why I love this question because
it's question I've asked before so this
I think that let me just preface my
answer by saying I don't think my answer
is the only answer and I'm not sure that
the FDA would agree but I'll give you my
opinion on it and that is you'd want to
start with a master cell bank that was
not edited and then
you would make essentially working banks
that would be genetically modified but
all that then has to be done in the GMP
environment and you have to fully
characterize that the working cell Bank
is genetically modified so you may not
have to redo all the the viral testing
but you will have to do two netic
stability on that working cell bank our
next question is we have a cleanroom
that is not GMP can we manufacture our
material there and use it for clinically
representative pre-ind studies so for
for a cleanroom that's not GMP I think
if you're making your your working cell
banks or so called GLP material that
it's going to that follows the supply
chain and the batch records in the
process that you're used for making the
end product you can you can manufacture
material for your pre-ind studies
it's not in a GMP environment however
the master cell bank that does have to
be GMP so at some point you're going to
have to make a break and make that GMT
master cell bank knowing that you can
take some of those vials back to a
research lab which is clean but not GMP
and make essentially development or
research working cell banks and under
GLP or sufficient quality to to meet
regulatory requirements you can make
your end material but you can't you
can't skip the GMT master cell bank so I
guess when you get into final or actual
phase one manufacturing for patients
everything soup-to-nuts has to be done
in the GMP environment but if you're
making material for pre ind-enabling
studies preclinical and animal studies
that it has to start from a GMP master
cell bank but you could make it under
GLP in a less clean or less less
controlled environment for ind-enabling
studies
Thank You Ben and we appreciate a live
participation from our audience we have
time for a few more questions our next
question is what is the difference in
the cost of cell culture for GMP
products and for laboratory purposes the
probably the biggest cost is oftentimes
research use only or are you oh I didn't
spell that out in the talk are you oh
just means research use only and a GMP
product often there's there's very
little maybe no difference in how
they're made the difference is in the
the amount of labor and time and
documentation that's required to
differentiate between between a GMP
product or a cell therapy grade product
and a research use only product so
that's that's why there's so much more
cost it's in the human side and the
liability that is involved in that for
the for the supplier so GMP reagents are
just by nature more expensive because
there's a lot more traceability that
goes into that testings more extensive
things like that so when you're working
in a GMP environment the same kind of
thing it's the lab will look the same
it'll have an incubator will have a
biosafety cabinet you know it's it
doesn't it operates like any other lab
would except for the fact that you have
to have controlled entry controlled exit
you have to have traceability and the
environment you have to have
traceability on operators traceability
on all these machines and so just it's
expensive of keeping that record and
keeping that cleanroom is what causes
the GMP prices to go up and it's so in
the short end the difference is really
traceability and human labor that's
required for that and therefore that is
what increases the cost between GMP and
non GMP
thank you for that answer our next
question which molecule molecular assays
do you suggest for testing genetics
ability of the MGB right now the the
assay which is and not molecular it's
it's a it's gross morphology essentially
is dban G band is considered the the the
gold standard and it's what's used to
test for genetic stability so you'll
look at say 30 to 50 cells and you
should see the carry type should be
normal stable a lot of groups are now
starting to add in new or technologies
whole genome sequencing
we've got integrations looking to see if
there's any sort of especially for type
one stem cells if there's integration of
your of your your clear potent genes
into the the genome of the cell of
interest i I mean there's I think
there's a fair amount of assays that you
can use to give yourself comfort to give
your investors comfort to give your
patients and your physicians comfort
that you have a stable line but right
now the required requirement would be
would be karyotype
Thank You Ben and we have time for one
more question our final question is what
are the consequences to not using a GMP
master cell bank your IND won't be
approved so to do a lot of work and you
won't get you won't you won't be able to
begin clinical trials
then do you have any closing remarks
that you'd like to share with the
audience Dale no I well I guess a yes I
do so I just like to thank everybody who
came and and participated listened to
our talk if you have any questions you'd
like to follow up with you can find us
at our website laura sticks comm and I
look forward to hopefully meeting some
of you in person and if we can do
anything to help you we'd love to help
and I'd like to also thank thermo Fisher
and lab roots for for the time and
attention today and for inviting me to
present this has really been fun thank
you
and before I go out I tell also thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration the webcast
can be viewed on-demand through August
2019 leverage will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event a poll will now pop
up on your screen and your answers and
your suggestions will help improve our
webinar program and they are greatly
appreciated until next time bye bye